oh he was doing Top Gun quotes while we
were flying in formation all the
helicopters when we'd finished doing our
New Zealand portion were flying in
formation
that's right and sitting there with our
headphones on and Tom started doing Top
Gun quotes what quotes did you whip out
I've got a knife I don't know sometimes
like I'll be flying because I'm a pilot
that P51 in the movies that's my p15
what's really amazing you know you're
not allowed to talk on lines but they'll
know that it's me in the plane or
they'll hear me and they'll be like how
about I feel the need
for a speed all right talk to me Goose
talk to me goose
to fly by you know yes Tower this is
Ghost Rider requesting a flyby